i'm laura ingram and this is the ingram
angle on a triumphant friday night from
new york
answered prayers that's the focus of
tonight's angle
on january 22nd 1973 almost 50 years ago
seven members of the supreme court held
that under the 14th amendment of our
constitution the same constitution that
americans had fought and died to protect
elected officials could not protect the
unborn from abortion
now ever since that time abortion has
been a constitutional right
now this was a painful and humiliating
experience for tens of millions of
americans who love this country
and who were shamed to think that our
constitution would be used to justify
abortion
but the pro-life community never gave up
on this country
we always believed that someday roe vs
wade would be overturned
and this blot on our history would be
purged and today was that day
this is amazing this is probably the
best day of american history in my
lifetime
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now look at all those young women and
men celebrating life
that is the future of america the
pro-life movement but there are still
some who consider abortion a holy
sacrament
and they're furious they're trying to
intimidate the justices at their homes
threatening to defy the court they're
desperate to inflame the nation as it
was in the summer of 2020
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the 5-4 majority that overturn roe and
dobbs simply returns the issue of
abortion to the states where it properly
belongs
it will be legal in many states but
illegal or highly restricted in others
until the people decide differently
it's called the democratic process ever
heard of it but people who should know
better of course they're engaged in what
can only be described as pathetic and
lame efforts to misstate and twist the
ruling
chief among them joe biden himself
it was three justices named by one
president
donald trump
were the core of today's decision to
upend the scales of justice and
eliminate a fundamental right for women
in this country state laws banning
abortion
are automatically taking effect today
jeopardizing the health of millions of
women
some without exceptions
so extreme that women can be punished
for protecting their health
core principles of equality
liberty
dignity
and the stability of the rule of law
demand that rose should not have been
overturned
with this decision
the conservative majority of the supreme
court shows how extreme it is
how far removed they are from the
majority of this country this decision
must not be the final word
well wait whoa whoa whoa wait a second
i thought court rulings were the law of
the land joe oh is that out the window
now okay i have to keep up i have to
take notes here now this is just typical
of people who
know what they're doing is wrong and joe
biden as a catholic should be ashamed of
himself to use the word dignity to
justify the old roe versus wade ruling
perhaps the worst though was biden's
attempt to conjure up phony emotion did
you catch this moment he was invoking
outlier cases in order to whip up
political support for their lifeless
party
it's a realization of an extreme
ideology so extreme the women and girls
were forced to bear their rapist
child
the child of consequence
that's it
it just it just stuns me
what a phony i'm sorry if democrats
think that this is going to help them in
november they're going to be sorely
mistaken
it's usually not good for any political
movement to be losing and americans are
seeing that the populist movement is
winning and it's succeeding
hispanics who are more pro-life than
most democrats they're not going to turn
away from the gop because they suddenly
want more abortions and no one's going
to tolerate a terrible economy
wasteful war spending and an incompetent
gerundocracy just so more people can get
more abortions that is ludicrous
and notice the difference by the way
between the way we react to losing at
the court and the way they do
now pro-life forces
lost 50 years ago
it was devastating to them but they
never stopped believing in america never
they still believed in the system and
they worked within it to arrive at the
ruling that happened today
now they elected pro-life republicans
they held countless prayer vigils they
pushed for pro-life language in the rnc
platform
they wrote op-eds they held debates they
did campus outreach they started crisis
pregnancy centers many of which are
under attack now
remember they conducted sidewalk
ministries and were ridiculed for it
they hosted and attended the march for
life for decades in rain in ice and snow
in shine
and of course
they elected donald trump
who would put not one but three justices
on the court and the majority today and
let's not forget
he was the very first sitting president
to speak live let alone attend the march
for life
unborn children have never had a
stronger defender in the white house
every life brings love into this world
every child brings joy to a family every
person is worth protecting and above all
we know that every human soul is divine
and every human life born and unborn is
made in the holy image of almighty god
now this isn't in the prompter i'm just
going to say this okay
that was the best speech i think he ever
gave and he's given a lot of great
speeches
that was really
special meanwhile the left
they lose once at the court and they're
threatening to tear down the whole
system
they want to take down the senate they
want to blow up the electoral college
and now the supreme court itself they
hate our constitutional democracy
but this decision like the gun decision
yesterday
simply follows the plain language of the
constitution
remember the second amendment clearly
provides for the right to keep and bear
arms and the left they're like no it
doesn't right meanwhile the constitution
says nothing about abortion but the left
claims it is a constitutional right
constitutional rights can't be made up
out of whole cloth it's ludicrous but
that's what the court stupidly did in
row
the left side's the need for a living
constitution don't you love that
now talk about twisted logic where a
document must live
and be protected for living while a
pre-born human being must have no right
to life at all
very logical
now as much as the establishment the big
business media they work to silence and
demoralize the pro-life movement all
these years it didn't work
the pro-life movement was not left
behind it didn't fade away its members
didn't grow old and die out instead it
kept renewing itself
and it grew stronger and younger year
after year decade after decade it
continued
of course we still had a problem
because too often republican presidents
and you know who you are
promised to appoint pro-life justices
but didn't keep their promises
justices o'connor suitor and kennedy all
voted with the judicial activists on
these and related cases on abortion
now had conservatives including yours
truly not force george w bush to pull
the nomination of harriet myers back in
2005
she would have been another vote to
uphold row thank goodness we have sam
alito on the court
now we always seem to be one or two
votes short didn't we over all these
years but in 2016 pro-life voters saw a
chance to change the republican party
and the court
so donald trump wasn't part of the gop
establishment was he he wasn't one of
the politicians who had led us on for
decades all lip service only to
disappoint us at the end
he promised to be different he was a
threat to the old guard he promised to
appoint pro-life justices who would hold
firm no matter how many threats they
received from the outside
so gorsuch kavanaugh amy coney barrett
all voted the right way
many republicans doubted those promises
by president trump
but most of us decided to take our
chance and in the end president trump
kept this promise
mitch mcconnell and the republicans in
the senate they kept their promises as
well
and today for the first time since 1973
our constitution is free of the taint of
abortion
now this court this decision
solidifies president trump as one of the
giants of american history
for many americans this is like the
berlin wall coming down
something they hoped and prayed would
happen but in their gut they never
thought it would really happen
all those who claim that trump would be
bad for conservatism
they owe him an apology tonight if
you're honest with yourselves you will
apologize
he got more done in four years than the
bushes did in a combined 12.
there are times when we all wonder
whether it's worthwhile to spend so much
effort as we do in politics gets tiring
gets depressing gets demoralizing
we march we pray we donate we speak we
go on tv we write we organize we vote
and many times you can't tell really if
you're making much of a difference are
things really getting any better i don't
know
but some days it's different some days
you win and some days you get to
celebrate and give thanks that you were
alive when our prayers were finally
answered and the united states of
america finally did the right thing
today
is one of those days
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else